[Music]
kids want to have all sorts of jobs when
they're younger from doctors to riders
and everything in between there are
plenty of professions available but
those jobs weren't meant for these kids
stick around to find out one child's
elaborate plan to rule the world if this
is your first time here make sure to let
us know by giving this video a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe for more
videos like this one now let's check out
10 hilarious kids who answered when I
grow up perfectly like mommy when we
were younger
most of us looked up to our parents we
admired their jobs and wanted to be just
like them when we'd grow up this meant
that some of us wanted to be teachers
writers vets doctors and so on and on
but this mama seems to have a slightly
different profession even though the
child still admires her judging by the
poll and the money that people are
holding in their hands it's safe to say
that we all know what this mother does
for a living we just hope this innocent
kid didn't have to watch her mom at work
because that's just not okay 100 years
old okay this one isn't exactly in the
when I grow up style but we have a
feeling the original intent was the same
however this kid is definitely thinking
outside of the box or in this case
breaking out of the box when gran was
asked the question what he'll be doing
when he's 100 years old he drew a
picture of a graveyard and him breaking
out of his tomb this is definitely way
better than any typical when I grow up
story we have ever seen but it's pretty
clear what this child wants to be when
he grows up he wants to be immortal good
luck kid a dog some of us have very high
standards of what we want to be when we
grow up and others not so much or maybe
they do depending on how much you love
dogs this adorable little kids that he
wants to be a dog when he grows up come
to think of it this wouldn't be such a
bad idea we'd always be happy everyone
would love us and we get to run around
all day without having to pay any taxes
rent or bills we've changed our minds we
want to be a dog too if anyone knows
where we can sand our CV let us know
mailbox yes you heard that right there's
a child somewhere out there that once
wrote that they want to be a mailbox but
what's even better about this answer is
the picture they drew underneath perhaps
the kid realized that being a mailbox
won't be that exciting and decided to
draw a totally abstract
image instead who knows maybe this
mailbox comes with superpowers who are
we to judge kids on what they want to be
when they grow up go on kid be a mailbox
if you want to but in all seriousness
we'd love to know what this child will
actually be when they grow up a person
who stays at home let's be honest we all
want to do this well at least some of us
do Albert is all of us who want to ditch
the nine-to-five but still have enough
money to live for the rest of our lives
he wants to stay at home and do nothing
when he grows up while there's nothing
wrong with sticking to realistic
ambitions we feel this one is just a
little bit concerning come on Albert
surely there's something you want to do
when you grow up although seriously the
kid has a point that's exactly what we'd
like to do right now stay at home and do
nothing i customer unknowingly this kid
basically described an adult although
most of us don't buy these exact same
ingredients we feel like a lot of people
actually do when asked what she wants to
be when she grows up
Alena said that she wants to be a
customer in a store she wants to buy
broccoli tomatoes and carrots and make
soup out of them when she gets home that
does sound like a really nice vegetable
soup
maybe Alina really just wants to be a
chef not a customer although who
wouldn't want to just shop their lives
away without worrying about running out
of money sign us up and we'd also like
some soup please ninja chef now this is
a profession we'd love to have we feel
like Jamie Oliver would approve of this
child's ambitions this kid even showed
us what they wanted to be at other ages
not just five and a half they want to be
a ninja chef and according to them that
title belongs to Jamie Oliver how cute
they even provided the schedule there'll
be a chef from Monday to Thursday a
ninja on a Friday but considering this
child already changed their desired
profession in just six months we have a
feeling the ninja chef won't last that
long but chefs are definitely ninjas we
can't even imagine the chaos that can
happen in a restaurants kitchen a wolf
we're getting flashbacks to the Twilight
franchise with this one kids sometimes
do want to be animals when they grow up
we've shown you someone who wants to
become a dog but this kid took it to a
whole new level what's better than a dog
definitely a wolf everybody would leave
you alone and you'd be known as one of
the most powerful creatures ever nuts
you'd be extremely fast it gets even
better if you have a pack of other
wolves following you around this kid
definitely has a good idea even if it's
not really practical watch out for the
full moon
mermaids this is one of the most
ambitious kids you have ever seen they
don't just want a job in the future they
want a job right now and they want it so
they can swim like a mermaid one day and
buy a mermaid tail cute right
we love that they're willing to babysit
small animals but only those who are not
evil and it seems like the kids heart
was broken when no one wanted to help
them out on their goal to be a mermaid
Mahon give this kid a pet-sitting job
just stay away small evil creatures
sport child would have small evil pets
done to you rule the world
this kid has one of the most elaborate
plans we have ever seen number one seems
fine as he probably will find two
girlfriends number two is also okay
because he will eventually kiss her but
then he goes from zero to 100 real quick
when he put rule the world as number
three talk about an overly ambitious
child who knew that it would only take
two other steps to rule the entire world
and it would all begin with finding a
girlfriend good luck kid it sounds like
his life will be extremely adventurous
what's your dream job let us know in the
comments that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to our channel and
hit that like button for more videos
like this one see you next time
[Music]